sir my name is orlando gutierrez-bornet
i
i represent the assembly of the cuban
resistance it's the main coalition
of pro-democracy organizations in the
cuban excel community
and um what i want to do is very briefly
share with you four memories of my life
that helped me understand what socialism
is
what communism is first of all i want to
thank god for this opportunity
for many different reasons and it brings
back one of my clearest memories of cuba
which was sitting
in one of those big beautiful havana
churches and the church was almost empty
my grandmother myself two or three more
people the priests doing mass
people were afraid to worship people
were afraid to go to church
because they would put mobs outside to
insult you when you came in or when you
walked out
and you would be discriminated if you
believed in god persecuted for somalia's
family
knows that experience very well and
everywhere communism and socialism have
come to
the first freedom they strike out is
religious freedom why are they knocking
down the statues of jesus because
they've done it
everywhere they've gone whether it's a
synagogue a temple a church
that's their their target saint
augustine said that the source of all
other freedoms was religious freedom
the right to believe or not to believe
to have faith not to have faith that's
fundamental
and that's one of the first things
communism in cuba tried to eradicate
they tried to wipe out christianity in
cuba
for this very powerful reason and for
many others
free cubans cuban americans have been at
the forefront of the struggle against
communism
in cuba and around the world
thousands of cubans have died in that
struggle thousands have been imprisoned
many are still in prison today it's been
a very long struggle
and this community has been visited many
times by different leaders who made a
lot of promises
few of those promises the most glaring
being the bail pigs
have been kept and that's why
one of the reasons why i thank god for
being here is that i wanted the
opportunity to thank you
because you came through i was there
when they gave me the bill pigs
award i was one of the speakers at that
day i was honored to do so
and what you said that day what you've
been working on ever since
closely with mario who's untiring
relentless in the struggle for cuban
freedom
you've come through and you know cubans
have been without a homeland for so long
we've been in this struggle for so long
that one of the things we cherish
is loyalty and gratitude and we are
grateful to you
and we're good friends to have because
we're
once someone has served the cause of
freedom in cuba and behaved like you
have we will be
loyal to you forever title three title
four have empowered cubans
legally to fight for justice the the
strategic sanctions aimed at the
military and the intelligence and
security sectors
have weakened them that's what we've
seen in the past months in the past few
weeks
protests against this regime in santa
clara and moa
in key cities in cuba every time cubans
see that the state is weakened and they
have a chance to fight
they fight they go out and they struggle
that's why
it's especially important at this point
in time that we have a strong radio
marty
a strong tv marti a strong republican
all these stations
which are transmitting uncensored
accurate objective information to cubans
cuba is the base for the communist
occupation of venezuela and nicaragua
if cubans are really supported like
you're doing now
to free cuba the entire hemisphere will
breathe better
including the united states the second
memory i want to share with you is that
right before we left cuba my parents
spent five years trying to get out of
cuba
my father for the crime of being an
electrical engineer they didn't want to
go
so he had to go to a work camp et cetera
et cetera a few days before leaving my
father took me to different places in
havana to show me havana before we left
because he said you know we may never
come here again and he never returned he
never saw his city again
and havana was a beautiful city it's
been destroyed now by communism
and it's a beautiful city because
between 1902
and 1959 in less than 60 years cubans
took
that island from being devastated by
genocide and spanish occupation to being
one of the leading latin american
countries
with a thriving economy just to give you
an example which
nobody ever discusses before 1959 cuba
fed itself and exported food to the
entire hemisphere
cuba today cannot feed itself without us
donations of food
so
we have lived firsthand what you are
struggling against
those many in media and in hollywood
who who spread lies about socialism lies
about communism lies about what happened
in cuba
people are naive about socialism they're
naive about communism
himself said that the goal of communism
and socialism was to destroy the
individual
to destroy individualism that's the
engine of freedom that's the engine of
prosperity compare cuba today
with israel or with taiwan and by the
way this community also thanks you for
your support for israel and taiwan
look how those countries are doing same
size very similar to cuba
they've prospered cuba has collapsed
so my last memory
is the 24th of february of 1996
four cuban americans were massacred over
international airspace trying to help
people who are escaping cuban refs
we urge you to consider the indictment
of royal castro for that for that
massacre
and that the regime be tried an
international tribunal at cuba and
nuremberg for their crimes against
humanity
like that massacre and many others that
it has committed
that regime must be removed they won't
do an opening
they won't do elections it's a regime
which will remain in power until the
cuban people have the support
to take it out and
what i want to end with the last memory
is
i was my grandfather's only grandson big
family only grandson
before we left cuba my father went to
see his father
and my grandfather said without
hesitation get him out of here take him
out of here there's no place for
to grow up i want him to be a free man
i'm very proud to be american i'm very
proud to be cuban because i have a debt
with him i haven't dealt with my parents
for my grandparents
and with this country so count on us
there should be a task force to educate
americans about socialism and communism
and we're here to fight for cuba but
also for the united states thank you so
much and god bless you
thank you very much great job thank you
please
yes i'm very sure
listen before i start
i need to first thank you for
your sacrifice and the job you've done
and i also want to make sure that we
understand that you are surrounded with
very good
people here in the state of florida
and just to mention a few we have the
best governor and lieutenant governor in
desantis and jeannette nunes we have the
best two senators
in mario and murray is a congressman but
the two senators scott marco the best
congressman for sure guys sitting to
your left
my dear friend and i cannot forget
somebody
who is just being promoted very recently
or i hope he gets vetted
in front of the senate our dear carlos
tuji a very young man with a tremendous
future
thank you very much because you have
selected those people
and i assure you they will be eternally
loyal to you
when they have your back i assure you of
that
now my story is very simple
we always talk about socialism
socialism is nothing but communism
during halloween there's no such thing
as socialism
america has always been the most
socialist country in the world
we're definitely the most generous look
at the people in this table
look at our backgrounds
think that in 1961
as a 13 year old by myself
on my way to spain i wasn't even coming
here
i arrived in this great country
and almost 60 years later i'm sitting
next to the president of the united
states
talking about the american dream
the only country in the world no other
country in the world
that you can start a business from the
trunk of your car
and within a very few years with hard
work
commitment and all the core values that
we learn
from this very culture of ours
we can become very important
to our future we can become those people
who make the next generation better than
the one before
this is the only country why do you
think you had to close the borders
because everybody in the world wants to
come over here
nobody's ever forced to come over here
we come over here in my case
because my parents chose that will not
be indoctrinated
by the communist country by the
totalitarian country
by the totalitarian regime they don't
educate children
absolutely not
and this is something that we need to
understand
what is happening in our backyard today
i experienced as an 11 year old
i remember vividly
all the promises that a guy named castro
gave on how
99 of the people swallowed the pill
it took many years later after i read
somebody named saul alinsky that i
realized
that all those people were nothing but
useful idiots
i remember castro while in the mountains
being
interviewed and asked if he was a
communist
he went crazy i dare you he says
catholic romano
a roman catholic educated by the jesuits
he was
how dare you we even have a priest in
the mountains
he used to have prison the mountains i
remember i was the mary's brothers
christopher columbus here for those of
you know
and i remember the brothers the marriage
brothers used to send young kids to the
mountains because it was the second
coming of
our lord he was going to save cuba
i remember how he promised to the
farmers
to the wajitos that you're going to own
the land
i remember
all the promises that we hear today
about free education and free health
care
and free land my god
no freedom but he never said that
until after he was in power got rid of
all the police
got rid of all the military been there
for the last 60 years
and counting
and he destroyed each and every one who
helped them
the catholic church
everybody what do i know that
because i happened to come to this
country
with the very last nine cloister nuns
from convento santa clara
because he had taken over the convent
and i was on my way to spain i wasn't
even coming here because i was going to
join my brother
who my parents had already sent
a few months before because he was in
the age where the government will take
them
for indoctrination purposes my dad
who had experienced the same thing
coming from spain at the turn of the
century
running away not from socialism
communism
he knew better i remember when he used
to tell my mom
fifa this sob is a communist
my mother says look how can you say that
he's catholic look he's worse he's got
rosary bits all over his neck
it just so happened that when i was in
my way
to spain to meet my brother i was gonna
go to the mary's brothers in la coruna
espana
same brothers here at christopher
columbus by the way
my brother died
and i was kept in this country
greatest blessing i ever had
but imagine what happened to mom and dad
one day you lose both kids this is a
family
who had never been involved in politics
my father came at age 18 from spain
running from communist
by himself never went back
after a long long life of sacrifice
when he was about to enjoy the fruit of
his labors just like a president that is
helping us today because he could have
been
just having a good time one of his many
beautiful golf courses
i know but yet he
gave up enjoying the fruit of his labor
to do this
so did my dad that's why i love you
exactly the same
so when they're about to do that from
one day to the next
they end up in this country with the
shirt that he was wearing on his back
a little maximum i've been here already
four years
but thank god for pedro talking about
socialism
catholic church 14 000 kids who came
like me in this country
without parents
and we were provided an opportunity
this is what makes our country great
they didn't give me free nothing
they gave me the opportunity that is the
most valuable thing
in the world now when i said didn't give
me any free
something please understand that at 13
years old
i had to be provided with a home not to
be provided with food
on an education
that is socialism
that's americanism that's the america
that these people are trying to destroy
today by using
funny terms like socialism they're not
the communist
don't ever forget that i know
our president understands that because
he knows he's been all over the world
and you're surrounded with great people
very loyal people
we have our back i remember the first
time i gave
a little speech about something like
this we tell him about
i came from cuba and blah blah blah i
remember
this is around october 2016.
i thought you were a little crazy for
the sacrifice you're about to take
but i predicted that we're going to let
you in november and i was going to see
you in the white house in january
thank you very much
because of the situations right now i
cannot give you a hug otherwise
thank you very much and i'm going to
leave you with one last thing
never forget about my dad who only had a
sixth grade education but i think he was
the greatest philosopher i ever met
he used to tell us how lucky he was
because he was able to come from spain
to cuba
and then he came from cuba to united
states
and he saw me graduate from college and
that was the biggest price he ever had
and he said
don't lose this place because you're not
going to be as lucky as me
because if you lose this place you have
no place to go so with that
please keep that in mind and please
people
explain that to our young people who are
demonstrating out there
don't be useful idiots please understand
what's happening in our country so what
happens to our parents
and see what is happening to america
today mr president thank you very much
and thank you for your hard work thank
you very much and he became one of the
most successful men in florida
so he did that's the only thing he
didn't say but he did and he's a great
gentleman thank you very much that's
very nice
and now that you've cut everyone else
down to about one minute we appreciate
that
okay do you mind let's go i asked
you you know okay thank you very much
appreciate it
thank you mr president my name is
lourdes
and i've been working in the media for
over 25 years in venezuela
latin america and the us and i mean i'm
an immigrant
uh the victim of socialism not once but
twice
i was born in venezuela to exile cuban
parents
who escaped the castro communist irony
and made a very successful life
in other times prosperous but always
generous
venezuela for every
single venezuelan life change when
socialist
corrupt golpita ugochovis
came into power in 1999 after two
decades of socialism
in venezuela the country is destroyed
we are a poorer society with a failing
purchasing power that limits the market
for almost everything
79.3 percent of venezuelan families
can't afford device the basic food
basket
child mortality has dramatically
increased
more than five hundred thousand
households between
ranchos what we call like favelas just
one
out of four homes mr president
has running water every day
just one out of 10 homes has power
every day out of 7.8
million children in the country 40
report difficulties to attend school for
problems with water supplies
blackout no food at home lack of
transport or lack of teachers
in conclusion around half of the more
vulnerable population can complete
12 years of school or graduate which
will
help in some way to reduce the risk of
remaining in poverty
we are 28.4 million people
because about 5 million
of us are abroad migration
made us not only fewer but older
we have more senior citizens more
fragile
in terms of health and productivity our
society is therefore less
able to produce wealth and more in need
of different ways of assistance
this is the reality mr president of six
out of every 10 venezuelan families
this number places venezuela as the
poorest
country in latin america and the
caribbean right now
chavismo destroyed the economy our
internal capacity to produce food
and basic services it ravaged the old
industry to the point that we can even
produce our
own gasoline above all this mr president
transnational organized crime
controls venezuela drug
cartels colombian guerrillas
international mobs
an iranian finance terrorist operates
freely
under the chavista regime with the cuban
agenda
how mr president a hungry
broken and sick country that has tried
everything to get rid of this criminal
regime
bathing our streets with the blood of
the youngest
our political prisoners exiles
torture and disappear under the
dominance of organized crime
how can they relieve
themselves by themselves from this
nightmare
you have been the only president
who has stood firm against these
criminals
neither president bush much less
president barack obama have to say
who privileged his relations with the
castro tyranny
by sacrificing the venezuelan democracy
they did nothing for venezuelan to
regain
their freedom venezuela is kidnapped
by the organized crime your actions
president are the only hope for
venezuelans who wake up every day let me
tell you
every day they wake up looking at social
networks to find out
if there is a new measure by donald
trump against that genocidal regime
other than that mr president the
greatest enemy
of our christian jewish civilization is
the iranian regime
as you know mr president the iranian
regime is the main allied of the
criminal regime in venezuela
they are not longer in asia they are
here two and a half hour flight
from miami the iranian regime has it
based on criminal operations in
venezuela and that represent an
imminent danger to the security of the
usa
and all of us u.s citizens and americans
today i ask you not to leave venezuela
each minute that passes is one of the
greatest suffering
for venezuelans
accelerate mr president the freedom of
our country
at this moment only a leadership like
yours can finally achieve the freedom of
venezuela
on behalf of the venezuelans my family
and my own
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you very much mr president
beautifully stated thank you very much
we're working very hard you know that
okay i know thank you very much thank
you very much and thank you very much
mario
congress mario diaz-balart he has been
the best friend we could
that we could have also the venezuelan
community thank you very much thank you
president great job
mr president it's a great honor to be
here to see you
again um my name is mario bramnick i'm a
local
pastor in south florida we also have the
latino coalition for israel
following uh your great work of moving
the embassy and you've been the best
friend of israel
that israel ever has had i also had the
honor of serving on the national
hispanic advisory council for 2016 with
jenny corn and now and the advisory
board of latinos for trump
i cannot express our gratitude for the
sacrifice
that you and your family have made for
our nation
and as has been shared here
all of the enemies of america are rising
in inside of america and globally to
defeat
your presidency in 2000 2020.
we can see because of what god is doing
in your life and over your life it is it
is god's hand
as a modern day cyrus that's upon you we
are so grateful
i was born in cuba and we fled communist
cuba to come to america for the american
dream
in 2016 after eight years of barack
obama
we were afraid what we fled from was
coming to the shores
of america and now we're being told
that barack obama and hillary clinton
are moderates
compared to the new democratic socialist
party of biden ocasio-saunders i mean
i think we should have a go fund trips
to venezuela and cuba to see how good
socialism would be
for our nation it's it's unheard of none
of us here would
have ever imagined that we would be
seeing
what we are seeing here um now i mean
it's really the socialist
anarchist anti-christian party um
the only good thing is that the american
public has a clear
description of what we're up against
the castro government murdered my wife's
uh father when she was five we visited
cuba a year ago and there's such
poverty and misery where professionals
make eighty dollars a month there's
shortages
of all kinds of food and they live in
buildings that would be unsafe
structures here
in america thank you for cracking down
on the castro regime
and reversing obama's data we as cuban
americans are grateful and applaud that
action
under a biden administration he would
undo
that action and begin to support the
communist
regime thank you before covet 19
we have the best record hispanic
unemployment of 3.9
lowest um poverty rate amongst hispanics
and the hispanic medium income was best
than ever
we're seeing an amazing economic
turnaround and you mr president
are our best hope to make america great
again
again there's no one else that can do
what you did and we know you're already
doing it now
and i've been with you so often i i i
we love you de amamos mucho i know your
heart for the hispanics i know your
heart for the immigrants
i know your heart for the
african-americans i was with pastor paul
a couple at the beginning
and i said at the end of your terms
terms
you will be known as a champion for
hispanic americans
and for african americans and i believe
all
will know because i know your heart and
your labor for our community
thank you we had the honor of being with
you yesterday at the rose garden for
your new white house hispanic prosperity
initiative
empowering hispanic americans to prosper
and
giving us the opportunity for each to
achieve
the american dream we as cuban-americans
uh
love president reagan many of us became
republicans uh during the reagan era
because of his strong stand
and strong economics but i believe that
you
are the best president for our community
in his
in the history of our nation and we do
see god's hand upon you we applaud
the u.s mexican trade agreement what
you're doing with mexico what you're
doing with central america
and i believe that cyrus mantle over
your life
also in a sense the leadership in our
organization we deal with heads of state
in latin america on their move of their
embassy
they're all looking to your leadership
to the vice president to this
administration
and really there's so much in the
balance and i'll end with this
we were at a white house dinner and i
said mr president we pray for you
there's a bullseye
on your chest and there's a terrible
attack against you your family and what
you have to endure
and we're praying for you for the first
lady and for your family
but it's not so much an attack against
you it's an attack against the soul of
our nation
you are what is standing between
capitalism and communism you
are what is standing between prosperity
and poverty between liberty and tyranny
for our nation
i would dread to think what would happen
if you're not our president but i know
with all that you're doing in
because of god's hell hand upon you that
we will prevail in 2020. if we lose 2020
we lose our nation
our freedom of speech our freedom of
religion as was mentioned
in our freedom of press and yet there's
a complicit press
not realizing what they're supporting
they're going to lose their own rights
it's 1776 all over again
and we are here with you praying for you
mobilizing to make sure that we don't
lose our nation in closing thank you so
much for your leadership for your
sacrifice
for your moral clarity your bold
determination
and your unwavering commitment to the
hispanic americans
to all americans and to our democratic
ideals
thank you so much thank you very much
professor very nice beautiful
thank you thank you very please
thank you mr president my name is
lorenzo di stefano i was born in caracas
venezuela
and i have a bachelor degree in
administrative
science in venezuela i started my family
and worked professionally in in the
insurance business
in the year 2000 i had an opportunity
for my business to grow
and political change in venezuela was
emerging
so i decided to move my family to the
united states
under a lang l2 visa
the initial idea was to stay four to
five years here in miami
then return to my country but due to the
political disaster in venezuela
we decided to choose an american
residency
and stay in miami i was lucky to invest
in the gastronomic field
which was a hobby a hobby for me
but it became a reality and so
i was one of the owner of el ar el paso
as the business was growing and due to
fire
in el el paso el er paso 2 was created
and in less than a year the partnership
dissolves
making me the sole owner of ella el paso
ii
i was there that my true feelings
towards venezuela emerge
i start to participate and get more
involved
with the problems that my venezuelan
brother and sister
live day in and day out i always i
always try to help
and give the best i could give from
miami
i saw uh how sad my
how son my venezuelan brother and sister
were of leaving venezuela
even though fleeing insecurity and
hunger
those who had the possibility of
arriving in miami
didn't know where to go how to invest
or work in short many of them
looked for help in my business and there
were always
people who could help them making a
repaso to
the venezuelan versailles mr president
venezuela was a paradise it had
everything
and unfortunately the mistake was made
to choosing a president
who would who would guide the country to
castro communist terrorists
and drug trafficking with this topic i
could
exceed my time therefore i want to
conclude with the following
mr president venezuela is already having
socialist
and communist problems on behalf of all
my venezuelan people american
republicans
i ask you not to allow this to happen to
the united states of america
and to please continue with more
sanctions
and more economic pressure on venezuela
since
we all know that a humanitarian
intervention is not easy to exercise
but neither impossible god bless you god
bless america
and thank you mr president and trump for
more years more
thank you very much beautiful thank you
very much
thank you so much mr president and truly
honored
to be here as a voice for freedom
of the cuban people and among self-dear
friends
thank you mr president for meeting with
us today
for your friendship and for standing
with us
the cuban people who wants to be free to
decide
our own destiny thank you mr president
also for your historic actions to
support democracy in cuba
and to pressure the cruel communist
dictatorship
our cuban people suffer constant
oppression
from the socialist state for more than
six decades
communist caster regime has imposed the
culture of the exclusion
and the discrimination against any
any cuban with a divergent expression
they abolished our civil liberties our
freedom of faith
and of speech they tried to delete our
history
our faith and our culture the castle
regime
tied the hands of the cuban people to
make us poor
and dependent because communism
mutilates
the human soul in order to control the
society
and those who raise their voice
in favor of freedom in favor of justice
those at risk in prison and even death
this july 22nd will mark eight years
since my father
oswald was assassinated
by the communist regime my father
founded and led
the christian movement for liberation he
was a leader
of the political opposition but he was
also a moral leader to thousands and
thousands of people who demanded a right
to have a voice
and participate to change the system
he was the most generous man i ever met
and he was killed by the communist
regime
they were trying to kill his legacy
because they were in fear
of the of the faithful
in fear of the conviction of a silent
majority
awakening and demanding freedom
and although they were although the
communist regime was able to kill my
father
they were not able to kill his legacy
they were not able to extinguish the
resolve of our people
to secure our liberation on the contrary
our resolve is stronger than ever we
carry on his work
our movement grows faster every day we
will not relent
until we are free we are going to finish
what he and many others started
i'm a freedom fighter but there are many
of us
among cuba and in this table also
and i know that you mr president you are
also a fighter
for the freedom of the united states and
the freedom of the world
mr president i invite you to join me
in commemorating july 22nd
to honor the victims of communism in
all the americas to honor all of those
who has fought
and died defending democracy
in venezuela in nicaragua in cuba
and in other parts of our continent also
it is important is vital to rise
our voices to call for liberation of the
political prisoners
and to stop the impunity of the castle
regime
the same impunity that castro felt
when he killed my father thinking that
the world was not going to react
mr president kuva is in crisis
families are living through a deep
humanitarian crisis
and political repression a crisis
caused by the existence of a corrupt and
criminal regime
and regime that has nothing to offer to
their own people
but repression and violence and that's
what they are implementing right now
against the citizenry
people are being detained threatened
escaped from their cell phones even
physically assault
beaten up in the streets taken to prison
simply for taking a photo in the streets
or posting in social media
that's the lever of fear and the
weakness
of the castle regime right now
this is why your solidarity and the
humanitarian help and the economic
opportunities that cuba needs
should be directed only towards the
cuban people
preventing intervention from the regime
because the repressors
should be cut out
we can on you mr president to continue
shutting down all of the dictatorship
sources of funding
which it uses to serve to sustain
the cuban military its apparatus of
oppression and its narco
terrorist activities
mr president this hemisphere has paid a
high price
for tolerating six decades of castro
communism in cuba
a regime that has caused the end of the
democracy in venezuela
and in nicaragua and the largest refugee
crisis of our lives
it is time to end it
the regime that infiltrated societies to
express
to spread chaos hate and division
and destabilize their democratic
governments
throughout the hemisphere and also here
in the in the united states
throughout the use of propaganda the
communist ideology has contaminated the
minds and soul of
young people in latin america
and in the united states it is time to
tell
them the truth president
trump this dictatorship
certain peace and security
of the continent as you know
they are involved in criminal and
terrorist related activities
drug trafficking trafficking persons
through the communist medical brigades
corruption providing sanctuary and
support to terrorists
mr president i encourage you
to indict raul castro diaz canel
and all top officials of the regime and
very importantly
i encourage you to designate the cuban
military
it intelligence services and the cuban
communist party as foreign terrorist
organizations because
their relation with the crime and the
narco terrorism
threatening the region
our movement cuba decides it's a
national and global initiative
to force the cuban regime to submit to
the will
of the people and leave it is imperative
that all the nations in the free world
support the given people's fights for
exchange
because the victory of the democracy in
cuba is essential
to open the path to peace prosperity and
stability
in the whole hemisphere mr president my
father
in a in in a letter to the congress to
united states he said
that we cubans we want to be free and we
want to be friends with the american
people
please accept this
coffin link with the
code of arms of the republic of cuba
as a symbol of the friendship
between our two people and also as a
symbol of our appreciation
for your actions and your solidarity
thank you so much mr president i'm
looking forward
to working together with you very soon
for the streams of the free cuba
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you very much well i want to thank
everybody i will not forget what i heard
today
it uh it's very moving it's a very tough
situation
and we've made a lot of progress as you
probably have seen and you know
and i have a feeling you won't be
disappointed
and by the way 2020 is very important
very important so good luck to everybody
thank you
really a good job beautiful job i won't
forget you have a great representative
right here so mario will be speaking
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
foreign